[Music]
all right we have some folks
joining us welcome it gives me
no short amount of pleasure to be able
to introduce
our feature panelists today and our
speaker
she as i mentioned is one of the icons
on campus
someone i have the honor of working with
the one and only assistant dean
of mba admissions and financial aid
kristin moss
so kirsten if you'd like to introduce
yourself and maybe any reflections on
the week
well will i must say that's one of the
nicest welcomes i've had in a long long
time so thank you i'm just feeding off
your wonderful
optimism and i i can't believe it's
22 i think that's right right real 22
events
and really as i re it's it's funny
because
we have been planning this event for
quite a long time
you're so busy in the weeds thinking
about what's to come you don't get a
chance to sit back
and ask yourself what will feel like so
it's been wonderful the day to just sit
in the emotions of the week and i think
the top one for me
is just a sense of inspiration right now
and it's inspiration to be with everyone
who's online for coming along this
journey with us
it's to be working with you will and the
rest of the community on this team i
know we've had
students and alumni and faculty and
staff
all come together to really talk about
diversity equity inclusion
an important issue and um over the last
really six months with what's been
happening in our world to see
one week in time where we can take baby
steps to talk about difficult issues
has been something that has filled me up
how about you will what are your
reflections on the week i
feel overwhelmed with gratitude
i would say just being able to share
space with our students
and just how open they were with their
experiences
things to think about kind of eat their
fears and hopes
um inspired by sessions but like earlier
we had one with
um laurie mckenzie and sarah sewell
talking about not just the direction of
dei at stanford but also like ways that
we can incorporate it
into our everyday lives so just knowing
that
i'm surrounded by people who really care
um
it's just so invigorating um right this
is already
a job that i love like i am an
admissions nerd
um but to know i get to work with people
that
are also kind of nerds about the things
that they love
um it's just it's amazing that's great
that reminds me where it echoes for me
and the opening having john levin dean
john levin come and
talk about why this work matters to him
and knowing that he's really leading the
ship at the gsb and to hear so
authentically about not only
how it impacts our institution but the
rest of the world
that gave me such um his values aligned
with so much that you and i talk about
and
work towards so to see him speak at that
level
really empowered
me to continue doing this work it's like
the the north star of the school in some
ways and i know for us this year in
admissions
it's our number one priority is
increasing the ei
in our community so it was great to see
him speak so
so much from the heart about it yeah and
earlier even sarah
was talking about sara and laurie were
mentioning how you know big changes
can happen from small actions and it's
the things in the here and now that we
do
um that can have some pretty amazing
ripple effects so
um it's awesome it kind of feels like we
were just
together on the last office hours but
yeah so much has happened
since august um so i wanted to check in
just so we could share with folks
who are tuning in some of you who may
have been part of our
last edition of this um some of the new
things that have happened
um so maybe to kick us off with could
you talk to us
about the bold fellows fund that was
just announced in august
want to be able to like really highlight
some of the things that are that are
happening here
yeah and i want to make sure i say one
more thing too because the most recent
thing that just
happened was this week and this has been
an event
so diversity and leadership for many
years but it has never been so
comprehensive involving so many people
and i wanted to speak to why it was
important to me
if that's all right for a moment and
really and when we designed this event
and will gets a lot of the credit
what was what's most important to me and
serving as a dean of admission
is i believe everyone out there i'm
looking we have a 135 people in the
audience right now
everyone has potential within them and
it's our job as admissions officers to
help
whether you apply to stamp it or not
it's really to help you
embrace that and realize that and part
of what we believe
in this program is individuals
can't really we talk about dreams at
stanford that we're a place where
dreams can come true so we all hold them
inside our hearts
but they don't become realized until we
can visualize how to make it possible
and this week at least what was
important to me is trying to bring so
many parts of our community together so
no matter who you are
in the audience and how you see yourself
and your identity
there are people here at stanford who we
hope
that you could see yourselves in and
people here at stanford are
already beginning to take those first
steps towards those dreams so if you can
begin to visualize
how could what's the legacy i want to
leave the
i mean that legacy i want to leave what
are the problems i want to solve and
then begin to see yourselves and some of
the role models here
that was really our hope and our goal so
hopefully some of you throughout this
week have gotten
one step closer to letting those dreams
not just be something you could obtain
but to make it real
of what you're going to obtain so does
that resonate with you will
so much because that really was the
heart of everything and it's not just
yeah this week wasn't about admissions
as much as it was
how can we how can we help people
like think big and see themselves you
know in business school
in business what are some of the ways we
can continue to grow
even if you don't go to business school
yeah um
and how if you do want to go like how
can we help you
put your best foot forward um regardless
of where that is
so um yeah that was just for the heart
of everything that this week is about
and
yeah and i think of all the literally
hundreds of students and others who have
been involved in having panels and being
able to take your questions and faculty
it's
um hopefully that was realized so let's
go back to bold what you talked about
first so we're launching the fellows
fund um i think our
john levin announced this just a couple
months ago and what is that about
why is it so important to us right now
we have been proud
at stanford for many years about our
financial aid model which is really a
need-based financial
aid model and that means we want to make
sure no matter what your financial
situation is that you can come to the
stanford gsb and not graduate with
unreasonable amounts of debt so we
really base our package on
you as an individual that being said we
know
that many students have put away their
savings especially if you're first-gen
or you're coming from a lower economic
status you may be saving right now like
our fly club talked about
you may be saving not only for this
moment in time but also for the future
to help others in your family or larger
community so this bold fellow
is really for you and you can apply for
it once you're admitted
and what we do is not only look at your
financial situation but also
that greater financial picture with your
parents and greater family included
so that we can help give a little bit
extra to ensure
that you have that protection over time
to face whatever
financial challenges might be in the
future for both you and your family
what would you and actually will has
helped create this so i'm going to toss
it to you and say did i miss anything on
that
i i think it it really speaks to
kind of the spirit of what we do in
admissions and financial aid like in the
application process we talk a lot about
the holistic review
but like this is our ability to
translate that into the financial aid
world as well
knowing like there are holistic parts
of who you are that might also need
support too and through the gsb
finances is one of them and how can we
be as thoughtful and inclusive as
possible knowing that you know
we're still learning we're still growing
we're still evolving and we'll always
keep changing based on feedback
um feedback is a gift um
but yeah it's i'm so excited for it this
year so
and i have to say too our alumni we've
been sharing this idea with our alumni
who are really excited to
contribute to the effort and part of
where it comes from for me too is having
really tough conversations once a
student's been admitted
even and i'm sure this has come up in
the week you know our financial aid
packages are generous
on average about forty thousand or
eighty thousand dollars over the two
years
even with um that package just having
insecurity about can i take can i invest
in myself and maybe take some of the
resources that i've saved that my family
might need
and those can be difficult so this is
the program that we've come up to really
help
with that pain point yeah yeah i know
that there
have been some pretty tough
conversations recently so i'm glad we're
like again every step forward is is a
step forward
um speaking of kind of steps forward
and we've also taken a step forward with
our
class profile um so we brought in a
class
during a pandemic it was very exciting
yeah so um we'll definitely talk about
that in a little bit but i also wanted
to
have you share a little bit about our
approach to the class profile and
how we're reporting like who our
community is with the public
yeah we wanted um in the last couple
years we've been talking about how to
make sure
for our applicants who are applying they
could really understand the richness of
the community at the gsb
and we have published in the past what
our underrepresented minority figures
are
as a percentage of our entire class so
that would be
looking at asians hispanics black
students native americans hawaiian
native hawaiians etc together but we've
never broken them
apart individually um this year
was and i said this has taken we've
really had an effort
i think for the past three years and
even prior to that but the bunsen burner
has been going up a little bit more
more and more energy um and i was
really excited to
share that our profile this year has
moved from i think last year's about 27
percent under represented minorities to
37
which is a huge movement in the needle
in a year and it really represents
a lot of outreach effort that we've been
doing on the team
leveraging our students and others in
the community to reach out
and encourage more people to apply as
well as um
helping students who are enrolled think
about the process and whether they could
be at home here so
first big news for us was we continue to
have a much more diverse class
but then within that what does that 37
mean how can we be more clear about that
and it sounds easy that you could just
break this out by different identity
groups ethnicities
and races for instance but as will and i
continued to
look at the profile of our class we saw
that a great
number of our students identify and
multi-ethnicities
and identities and it's and it's very
hard to put
one person in any individual bucket so
we really came up with multiple ways to
show the class
both from a sense of um how
the federal government regulations look
at ethnicities but also how we as the
gsp do which is really from a
multi-ethnic lens
so will i'm going to pass it ah look at
you you've got a slide i love that well
i came ready oh you're so good do you
want to explain that
yeah so i think one of the parts about
this that was so meaningful for me
like i always talk to people about like
who are you
um like what are the different elements
of
kind of your identity your lived
experience that shape the way you move
through the world
like if you've gone to any of my info
sessions like
you're gonna hear that um and the way
that we've
used to report by federal guidelines we
weren't able to capture some of that
complexity especially as it comes to
the identities of folks with mixed or
multiracial backgrounds
and so with the genius help of some of
the folks in our central marketing and
communications department like we were
able to come up with a visual that
both acknowledges the separate kind of
components of identity
as well as the experience and identity
of being mixed or multiracial in and of
itself
and i know this is a conversation
kirsten both you and i have had with
students and also like on the road with
folks who are
curious to see like what does how does
this shape into the experience because
we often hear
like here is the black business student
association here
is you know the um asian business
student association but what if i
identify with more than one and i think
this also speaks to
kind of a lot of what's going on on
campus when folks are talking about
intersectionality
when they are working across and
building coalitions
um it's kind of identity is complex and
you know this is our way to try and
embrace and talk about
it so really proud about it and that's
why i was like i've got to show
magic there that's fantastic thank you
will and it also
makes us more accountable we've said as
a as a school that this is a priority
for us to
continue to build the diversity of our
student body and here's you know our
first steps to making sure that happens
and i know that was definitely one of
those big developments for us
um yeah and like biggest development and
this is where
i think we really transition into some
of the things that folks
on this call might be interested in um
is thinking about
like our role in admissions
this year has thrown so many curveballs
our way
um there have been some beautiful silver
linings like
37 students of color but
um can you talk to us a little bit more
about the class like we brought in a
class that is no small feat
um can you tell us a little bit about
kind of
what happened how did we get here i know
our last office hours we were in the
midst of it so they
couldn't really share much but now any
insights you can provide
yes we're um we i love how you termed it
will that we brought in a class there
were times this year when on the
admissions teams
we were not sure that we would be able
to do that of any size
um and my hat my hat goes off to many of
the folks who were applying last year
and are currently students
and for you many of you may be in the
admissions process now
one of the key issues was really the
uncertainty that not only will and i
felt
because we weren't sure you know how we
could make decisions when students
couldn't get tests or whether our
international students would get visas
or even whether recommenders could get
the recommendations in time
and everything that we were struggling
with on the other side you as an
applicant were also struggling with
so i think the biggest lesson that we
learned together as a team
and will you can correct you can add
your two cents too was stanford is all
about coming together
and caring about the individual and
trying to make sure that our decisions
have integrity but also really put you
as a student or an applicant at the
heart of those decisions
so for us many of the things we did
schools did different things across the
globe really
but ours were very focused on how do we
make sure we can
help our applicants know as much as they
can our process can have that integrity
and that we take your needs into
consideration
so we ended up some of the decisions we
made for instance
is anyone who is an international
student who didn't have
a visa come mid-july that was right
before school was starting all the
embassies were closed around the globe
we offered them an opportunity
to have a deferral for the next year we
also work with students many students
um i shouldn't say many but some with
covet head health issues or family
members who had health issues so really
working one by one with them
to figure out what was going to be the
best solution given the circumstances
and then there was for all the students
who did want to come we had so much
uncertainty throughout the summer of
what would the experience look like
and i know if you're thinking about
applying this year you'll be facing some
of those you know because covet is still
here
some of those same uncertainties so our
approach really was
um fireside chats with the students and
giving as much information as we could
i to be honest have been really humbled
by the experience
because you just don't you can't control
a pandemic and at every moment we try to
be as
really have integrity and truth and be
authentic about what we do know but a
great hope
that the fall would you know know that
we would be able to have uh
at least hybrid classes where students
could spend lots of times
together and that hasn't been the case
um
and i and we don't know what next year
will look like so um i'm humbled by just
how difficult it is to want to be
optimistic but also want to be clear
and let students make good decisions um
given what their position is at any
moment in time
yeah and like how many how many calls do
you think
or fireside chats do you think you did
this summer we did quite a few years
for sure i think um uh christine who
runs enrollment said she had
over 170 one-on-one calls with students
out of class of 400 who really wanted to
think through
you know whether this was the right time
and the right approach to school so
that's another example
crazy yeah i mean it's
funny because that approach like even in
our info session
we talk about it all starts with you and
it
is an investment in you and we operate
in that same way like how can we keep
you at the center
so just really appreciate how you've
involved students
in the process both kind of prospective
students and our current students
um i really appreciated how you
got feedback from students on both bold
as well as
in the process as we were designing the
new class profile and the types of
information
we were able to to share getting
feedback and actually
acting on it and whether or not we were
able to adopt it like
going through the honest steps of
exploration um
i just want to acknowledge and thank you
for that because i think that's
really important um and just speaks to
again like the community and how we're
taking accountability for this
well thank you will thank you very much
and so
stemming from the covid question i know
there's it's on a lot of people's minds
so
i thought it would be helpful to hear
from you but like
you know given deferrals and some of the
decisions folks have been making
for the next steps like how is that
going to impact or how might it impact
future classes will it great great
question
and our class last year for the first we
had the biggest cost
ever so i'll start there that we
admitted and it was about 20
students more than the class before so
about five percent bigger
and given that we had deferrals we
allowed our international students to
take deferrals for their visas
um we are still if i had to guess we
haven't set our class
size at this point exactly but i'm
guessing we will keep that size it may
not be forever but at least for another
year that will be
up at least those 20 students again one
of the reasons for that
is when we decide to give deferrals we
really it was this moment in time where
you want to
make sure that the future applicants so
those on the calls today
would still have a good chance to get
into stanford you want to make sure that
the current students who had already
deposited were treated fairly and then
you wanted to make sure those students
who might not get a visa
had good choices so we really worked
with students to come out with a
solution that we
thought would be thoughtful for all
three of those constituent groups
and what we found from working with the
students and doing some surveys about
who was interested in deferrals and
whether they would take them if their
visas didn't come through it was really
a smaller a small percentage of the
class
so we are feeling that you will have a
good opportunity to find a spot
at stanford and we might be a little bit
bigger this year who knows maybe one
year
but we want to make again balance
between all three of those groups to
make sure the process has integrity
across the different classes yeah also
major shout out to the students who are
helping us gather this information like
each way
yeah so it's kind of amazing how even
the students were rallying around each
other to understand kind of each other's
needs
um even before even before they met each
other in person or virtually
um so many of the international students
were calling me saying
don't worry worry i'm working on such
and such i'm just telling no matter what
you know he should come even if it's a
month later and he can't get here on top
it was great but um yeah we were
surprised even with kovid
how many students from round one round
two who had deposited decided
that this absolutely you know no matter
what we're going to come even with the
difficulties we might face yeah um
colvin wasn't the only thing that
happened this summer
yes dei diversity equity and inclusion
has been
like the focus of this week really um
and given
events from the summer um killing droid
floyd
brianna taylor arbury um rise of
and kind of re-emphasis on the social
justice
um and on so many of our like radars
um there have been questions through the
week about like
has has this impacted like the way we
think about admissions
um and like how can we unpass that a
little bit
um together yeah and together it's a
good word because will and i spend a lot
of our free time talking about this
together
um you know i've been involved it's been
an honor to be involved
with admissions for two decades at least
and i would say even
the first role i held in my um early
30s that was a long time ago that was
one of my
i would say at that time one of my top
priorities having whether it's gender
ethnicity
and so it's been a long history for me
personally
i must say though at this moment in time
the commitment to really ensuring that
the diversity of your class matches that
of our communities
that energy has exploded so i don't
think if i look it's always been
important to me
and my admissions work but especially
now it is at the top of the priority
list and it is a real recognition that
this country
is in a place that feels torn apart
these issues can't stay buried
so not only now is it um each individual
but it's us coming together
i feel real change is like a wildfire
you start having
sparks and each of those sparks begin to
catch on and that's how this week has
felt
but also how it's feeling at the school
i mean our whether it's our faculty
you'll see huggie if anyone stays on for
his session next building new cases
around diversity
every case that is written this year a
new case from the dean is part of our
racial
equity plan we'll have um an
underrepresented minority protagonist
the school stanford just committed to
hiring 10 new faculty members whose
expertise is within this
and then for us we continue now let's
get to the admissions
piece of it not only is it is it
building community so individuals can
see themselves and believe that this is
a place that might help them so an event
like we're doing now it's also in our
admissions process
and we have been doing training for
many years on how to think about
assessment
within through a diversity lens and
we're continuing to do that
one thing that i think is important and
i think
for folks on this call to understand
is assessment is always done within
context so if you look we look at for
excellence or
impact how people have been impacting
their communities and it's really about
given the resources that they've had and
given the challenges they're facing
so i know for i use this example
oftentimes for one and
one student who may maybe their parents
went to college and their grandparents
and their great grandparents
for another student maybe they literally
are the first person ever to get there
now just getting to college maybe the
same
kind of accomplishment as someone who's
fourth generation is
to you know hold an a average whatever
it is so that's in
in context for us those are both
enormous challenges that people are
facing from a very different place
what do you think about that will i
each every site like basically every
application i read i get this new
appreciation of like the holistic review
process
and like the way it allows us to to
understand
um kind of who people are what their
journeys are that excellence in context
because
excellence is amazing and for us to
really understand what that means for
you as an individual just like
like that element of context really i
think
speaks to kind the integrity of our
process as well and our
our honest like and how much time we do
invest in trying to understand
um so that is definitely admission
nerd speaking because to really think
about the foundation of our work as
something i appreciate
like and i think it's it's an important
point to make because there are a lot of
myths out there that there's only
one way to succeed or one level
of excellence however that's defined and
like we look for instance in our
application for
folks who are persistent who have grit
who overcome
challenges and the myth i'd like to
break is
for each of you to ask yourself what is
something that you've worked hard for
and what why was that meaningful to you
and that could be that in college you
had a job to support
your family or your parents or your
education it could be that you're the
first person to get to college again to
use that example
it could be that you're mentoring your
siblings or your larger family
these are moments in time where you've
made an effort to support others it
doesn't have to be necessarily you were
class president or the captain of some
team so
when we look at you holistically we want
to understand what was important to you
and the actions that you took
and there's no you know there's no sort
of standard for what
what excellence means in that in that
category
um you talked about so some of the
things of excellence
you mentioned like leadership and that's
actually your
area expertise leadership assessment
yeah and i think i think that's a great
skill set
and vision to have to like guide us
through the process
and so like i actually got asked this
question this summer
um so michelle if you're out there i am
still mulling over this question that
you asked me um
she asked how would you define
leadership
i took a long time to respond to her
then i
asked her to email me a couple days like
later so i have more time to think about
it i'm not gonna lie
when she emailed me i left it in my
inbox for a couple days because i was
still thinking about it
um and i continue to change like how
i approach and understand that question
i was wondering if we can get a sense
from you given
kind of your experience in the field of
leadership
what are some of your thoughts on how
would you define leadership
for me the definition i have a pretty
simplistic definition which i'll share
um but it's not just because something's
simplistically defined it doesn't mean
it's easy to do
how about that well so i think about a
leader
is someone who is able to influence
others
to help them reach a common goal
that's the simplistic definition but how
does someone do that
and i know here and i've spent a long
time thinking about this
and studying many other many different
leadership frameworks
and we do in admissions we're looking as
we're reading these applications
holistically for evidence of
take of leadership behaviors so of you
being able to
i guess of you helping
others achieve this a common goal
through your own influence
there's different domains of leadership
that help with that
and not everybody um kind of spikes i'll
use that word spikes across
all domains we often look for candidates
who may do
one of these work within one of these
domains as
as a favorite or one that really
motivates them one of the first ones
that we think about in admissions is
really it's
how you think the insights you have and
oftentimes i think applicants believe oh
it's just my test scores or it's my gpa
in fact for stanford that couldn't
couldn't be farther from that truth we
really are trying to find evidence in
your application of
have you some have you had an insight or
seen a problem that you've solved in a
way that has
helped your team shifted the direction
that they might go
um how have you used your thinking so
that others could come together and get
to
a place which you've identified as the
right direction
so that would be an example of the
thinking part
you also see leadership there's a couple
different domains i talked about this
persistence and grit and challenge
that's another place we're looking for
people who are willing to take
risks and then work really hard set high
goals for themselves
for some it could be you know it could
be
being the first to go to college for
someone else it could be
winning a swimming event or a marathon
for others it could be
you know playing a piano concerto better
than they've ever played it but we're
looking for that evidence that you're
working really hard for something that
you care about
and i will there's a couple there's two
other domains i could touch on do you
think it would be helpful because i
could geek out on this oh totally i'm
geeking out listening to you but before
we go on i just have one comment so are
you saying that there is a diversity
in leadership yes there is there's
had to get that in there but yeah i
would love if you could keep telling us
a little bit more about those other
domains
because that's a great word to use
because within each of these domains you
could demonstrate it in so many
different ways depending on what your
passions are
um the third one the third important
domains is how do you engage
others so how do you get them excited
about what you're interested in so you
can work together
and then the last one which i think is
important for this phone call
is how do you think about developing
others and it might not just be
individual
humans it might even be your cultures
and i find um
i know when i was early in my career
okay a long time ago it felt like i was
one of the only women on wall street and
i
and was often called upon to run
recruiting
or support our marketing campaigns or
um help other women who are coming in
the firm and it was a
this can be a big load for anybody who
feels like they might not be in the
majority they might be in the minority
no matter how that gets
defined and this really translates to
investing in helping the organization as
a culture grow
as well as helping individuals within
that organization so
you might be someone who mentors others
at work who
you might be the person who teaches the
newest analyst how to do excel no matter
what it is you might be the one who's
helping your brother learn
you know helping your brother apply to
college there's so many ways that you
could show that you care
about developing others so those are
just four of the bigger domains
that i think about and if you put these
together you really can
influence um folks to join you in
achieving great things
yeah again like the theme that i didn't
pulling through like
so many different ways and even in the
small moments
um in leveraging some of those
relationships and impacting
even on that one-on-one level like you
can have some
really outside outsized results from
there
exactly and we want to know about them
that if that wasn't clear
we want to hear about them so don't ever
take yourself out of the process because
you think that your results aren't
big however the world might define big
because that we're not looking for that
we're looking for the
impact that you've had um on the people
that you care about and the
organizations that you care about
on that point about counting yourself
out i know there is
there is a level of intimidation because
stanford um the the admission rate is
is low like just going to name it um
can whatever what are your thoughts on
like how
might someone approach it in our
admission process or in the application
process in a way that help
might help alleviate some of those like
concerns
it's a great question i want to have a a
thoughtful answer i i think first we
we start and i'll laugh because it's an
echo of what we said before it really
starts with you
so if you're thinking that an mba so
you're beginning on this journey that
you really
need not only the learning but the
community as well as
a chance to figure out who you are and
where you want to go if all that is
compelling to you
and are deciding to embark on this
journey really my best advice would be
to look at multiple programs because
they do have very different
um selectivity rates and stanford tends
to be one of the ones that's most
difficult
and and those selectivities actually
vary um a lot by
by program so trying to find programs
that you think
might fit you and and embracing that is
a
journey in of itself when it comes to
stanford in particular so that makes me
feel comfortable
saying you know what if this is
something you're committing to do do
your homework and
try to have multiple options um and if
you continue to be excited about
stanford
and are a little worried whether you
know that selectivity rate would
prevent you from coming the best advice
i can give you is we
we're we've just shared with you what
we're really looking for it's not about
a test score
or it's not about one gpa we're looking
for reasons to admit you
and i feel like lucky and i bet will
does as well that we are at stanford we
got lots of applicants who have those
great test scores and gpas
so we have the flexibility to really
look at who has made contributions to
their communities
who could bring us a diverse perspective
into the classroom
who is intellectually curious you know
is finding new ideas
and those are the heart the true heart
of our process
um so don't take yourself out just
because you can't
you know you think you didn't go to the
right college or you're at the right
firm or you're in the biggest industry
or your test score isn't in
the average those are not good reasons
to opt out
now i guess i conclude to say when you
sit back and ask yourself
where have i made a positive
contribution that i'm really proud of in
the last
you know since college to now if you're
not coming up with a
couple good examples then maybe stanford
isn't
the place for you but that's what we're
going to be most excited about learning
is you know how because that's our our
mission we want you to go out
and not only change your lives but the
lives of others and
um hopefully at some point will spread
that impact around the globe
yeah and there's something to be said
about that reflective process
um and the introspection that you
invest into not just the application
like in and of itself but yeah as you're
thinking about your goals
um to our essay question like what
matters to you
um and that question actually is
very meaningful for so many different
levels can you
provide insight into like how you think
about like the what matters and
like how would you approach like
why is that an important question for us
right and i'm gonna um i'll say one
other thing on the last question and
start right there and i'm betting this
resonates with you as well that at admit
weekend
and this happens every year i'll have
students come up to me and say
i came this close to not applying i
didn't think there's any way i could get
in
i came from a community college or my
you know gmat score was this
or um i did my gpa that first year at
school was terr
whatever it is and they're like i can't
believe that i decided to do it and i'm
here so just recognize if you
are having those feelings that there's
no way um
the only way to find out is to be
courageous and put that application in
okay let's get to the what matters most
question this was a question that was
here well before
i ever took my role and i am delighted
when i first started this job i remember
i was interviewed and someone said are
you going to change that question like
no
it's the best question i could imagine
for anyone earlier in their career
to be answering there's lots of research
on leadership that shows that by the
time you're in your early 20s your
values
are set so the things that you care
deeply about are likely not to change
very much over the next 40 50 years
so there's no better time for you to sit
back and think
who am i how did i become this person
what are the values underneath that are
important to me and have been driving my
behavior
because not um not only is it a good
time to check on that because your those
values are stable
but also there's been so much research
that
the leaders who are making large impact
in our world
do so through the motivation of what
their values are and through their
ability to communicate them to others
so as i work as an executive coach with
senior level executives it's the first
question i asked them
and sometimes people who are in their
40s and 50s haven't figured this out so
it is a great time for you to really
understand
um who you are and what's important to
you so that you have a true north star
to get to at this point and you're you
know at this magical tipping point in
your career
now when i look at an essay i'm really
trying to find
the essay the best essays i shouldn't
say the best the essays that are often
compelling that i'm reading
and when we when they come across our
desk in the admissions committee
is i'm reading about a real person you
know in all of its complexity
so the more that you try to think about
what will or i might want to read the
less it's really going to be you
there's only one answer of not there's
only there's one story your true story
of who you are it's hard to get to
it's going to be a little work getting
there but that's the story that we want
to know about
so the best advice i could give you
would be
spend some time you know um trying to
jot down
what you think is important and will
will's jesus too and then ask yourself
why
why is that important and try to
continue to
to go a little bit deeper and a little
bit deeper so that when you finally
understand those core values you can see
how it links back and
the choices that you've made but what
would you say i was a lot of talking
from me will
i actually i feel very much the same way
and i
actually continue to ask myself what
matters
and why on a periodic basis um
and it's actually a really interesting
exercise to do
like and it's nice because i don't have
the pressure of trying to apply
somewhere
so i'm able to like experiment with the
way i approach it
so yeah for folks who aren't in the
thick of applying
i think it could be something
interesting to do
and then maybe ask a friend or someone
to do it with you and then kind of talk
about it was a great idea yeah that's
gonna be one way also to like
put words to something that just
feels you because sometimes those parts
of you are
hard to articulate because like
they're you um so
yeah and trying to do that has i found
that to be really helpful in like
big decisions in my life independent of
school we hear too on our panels from
students that
they believe one of the most powerful
things they've done in their own
development was that exercise
they don't necessarily feel at the
moment they had to write that essay
that it was going to be so powerful but
hopefully it will give you good
incentive that later when they reflect
they realize how helpful that was to
understand you know where they want to
go next right
kind of similar in the vein of like core
values we do have a question from
angelia about
yeah um kristin mentioned that values
are set in your early 20s
pretty set for the next 30 40 50 years
how does an individual express their
value this does
how an individual express their values
evolve over over time like
what are your thoughts on that yeah
absolutely really thought-provoking
questions
it is and it was funny to hear you say
well the same thing that you
reassess and look back i think
the core the core things that you value
will stay the same but the
way that you will find um to express
them
whether it's in your work that your
family the things you do outside of work
will shift as you grow and mature
but they will be your probably your true
north
guiders that sit underneath it yeah and
there's
a range of questions uh in the q a box
so for folks who are tuning in we are
shifting into that direction
um a lot of the things that we were
talking about
have been either industry or
academic background agnostic and so
what are your thoughts on like for folks
who
are thinking about applying but don't
know like you mentioned earlier like i'm
not from the top firm or maybe i'm not
from an industry
like quote unquote i'm from a
non-traditional industry like that how
do you think
that contributes to those perspectives
contribute to the class
wow that's fantastic um question
diversity we've been talking about many
different kinds of diversity but that
and industry and your professional work
experience is one of the key components
of how we build diversity in the class
so
while some of you from traditional
industries are worried that you might
not stick out because you're from
consulting or finance others from an
industry
like education or energy may feel
also that you're not going to get in
because you're from something that's
very different
literally when we're looking at those
files we're trying to
create a conversation in each and every
classroom where you can have these
dialogues so
you might have someone it's not only the
industry well in the energy in the solar
business i was doing it this way well
when i'm selling
you know when i worked at the nba this
is what it looked like you know
that's how you have some dialogue but
it's also in a district
to industry we look at what your
function is so it's wonderful to have
someone in the room who has actually had
to sell something
who's had to build something to have the
engineer we have doctors and lawyers
we have a pastor we have a professional
violinist so
there are many different ways that they
can bring their point of view to solving
different
problems that are in the classroom yeah
and it comes back to like
anchoring in yourself and like the
perspective you bring
um dean levin actually opened diversity
and leadership
well i kind of stole his thunder because
i quoted him and then i because i didn't
realize what he was gonna talk about he
spoke about education fundamentally
being about
engaging and encountering difference and
how that kind of
has you challenge kind of your own world
view
and even if you don't have to accept or
agree with everything
like these are different ways for you to
continue pushing the boundaries of your
understanding
um so it's kind of nice how how this
does come full circle and how
like diversity really is a critical part
of both our identity as an institution
and how we want to keep evolving over
time
so i want one other thing since we're
talking about applications
though will is another misconception i
believe
is that you are your industry if that
makes sense
that somehow you know we're reading all
the energy
or all the education or the health care
and um that so much of your application
is because you have learned about this
thing
what i found fascinating over a couple
decades is
i can read you know 15 different people
who are doing
say private equity or you know
consulting whatever it is
and the way that they show leadership or
the way that they've impacted others
varies dramatically so this industry
it's not as if it's the lens we're
looking at you it's just one of those
things that are in your context
but please don't feel that that's what
you represent we're much more interested
in
what you have done within your
organization
and that and even the same company can
be dramatically different
yeah there's a question here
from hishki and this is a question that
really speaks kind of to a lot of the
work i do so that's why i'm
yeah kind of biased towards this
question what are some future
initiatives that the mission team has in
the pipeline and and
is and is excited about well will why
don't you start with that one
i'd love to toss it to you i'm i'm
really excited about not just
the expansion of audiences and trying to
really help folks see themselves at the
gsb but
how can we also leverage um the work we
do
the reach that we do have to help people
put
their best foot forward regardless of
what they end up doing so they might
apply somewhere else they might decide
to stay in industry but
in our outreach efforts can we
do some of the things that kind of
challenge you to have that
audacity to believe in yourself
like these new ways so that you can i
love it
have that creative confidence to like
see something through or try something
different um
and so while it's not necessarily a
tangible
singular thing that we're doing i think
it's almost that philosophy that
undermines kind of the spirit um
and actually that was a lot of what we
hope i hoped
to develop with diversity and leadership
this week to
not just be about admissions but are
there things that people can take away
whether it is realizations about
themselves or maybe small actions they
can do in their everyday lives
around the topic of diversity equity
inclusion so
super thank you for posing that question
yeah this is something that is so
meaningful for me and this this is
almost like my what matters that is
great
i love it well and it really i think it
really captures i'm lighting up because
it captures um
like if you think about our presentation
even from the last decade it's not
here your classes here's what the clubs
are it's really
who are you and what do you want to do
and i think i share will with you
so i lined so closely that our hope is
that we're helping you get in touch with
what you want to accomplish no matter
where you apply
and certainly stanford may not be a good
fit um
for every individual so it's this it's
great to be on the uh
to be in admissions role where your true
purpose is helping people reach their
potential no matter where
it's going to be the right place for
them so so well put will thank you
you could tell i get really invested in
again admission nerd stamford yeah it's
awesome um
so this is going to put you in the hot
seat kirsten um this is a question from
fulu
and again to everybody out there your
answer is your own and celebrate that
but we're curious for christine in the
here and now
what matters to you why
it's so um funny that this
i didn't even see this question on the
list but i love it
it's a very close will to what you said
my whole career if i could look back and
connect the dots has been about
trying to help people
essentially know what's important to
them and have the courage to step
in and expand what they think they're
capable of and i've been
really lucky to not only be doing
admissions work but also had a chance
at stanford for many years to work in
the classroom and
of course we call interpersonal dynamics
to help people their leadership skills
um after i left samford before i came
back again as dean
i was working in the private sector and
at an executive search firm doing lots
of coaching with
senior executives so it's so much a part
of
who i am and in this role it's a
wonderful platform to be speaking with
applicants who are early in their
careers you know almost every day
about what they want to accomplish and
how we could help them get there and
that really is what's most important to
me
thank you i know that can often be
[Laughter]
like thank you for like embracing that
question
um and i think that's just something fun
to like
hear from the leader of our admissions
team um to hear
you know what some of your guiding
principles are
i'll say one more thing about it too i
feel in this role
um different than in other times in my
career it's it's an enormous
responsibility
because if at the heart you're trying to
help people develop and we have an
opportunity to come to a place that
will and i both deeply believe in making
those decisions thoughtfully and trying
to do them with fairness and integrity
and trying to bring in so many um as we
said diverse perspectives in class it's
a lot of responsibility to
to do that right for the institution and
do it right for everybody who's on this
call
to treat each of you with um the dignity
and respect you deserve in the process
yeah so we we are starting to creep up
to the top of the hour
if you could have any parting words of
wisdom advice
um something that you hope folks can
take home with them
after today's session kristen like what
would that be
um the top card is
believe in yourself invest in yourself
that may not be the mba that's the next
step
but challenge your challenge your
dreaming and your visualization from all
of the wonderful stories you've heard
about
how will you step into your own power
how will you be brave
because we need you the world needs you
so that's my top card and then the
second card and i'm feeling this
much more in the last month as covid
continues the pandemic continues to heat
up
is be thoughtful about know that this is
a difficult time
and for you as an individual right now
think about your current situation what
you're learning how much
you can learn how whether it's social
justice or it is the pandemic is
affecting
you know that that runway that you have
over the next year to 18 months
because it is a difficult time for
everyone and whether
if you want to come to business school
it's not like it was two years ago but
probably it's your job isn't exactly
like that as well so just take some time
to think for such a big investment
um what given world the world isn't the
uncertainty what's right for you
what does that trade-off look like and
hopefully you can get some good advice
from
mentors around and folks like us on our
team to help you get a
greater clarity about that decision but
at the end of the day there's no perfect
choice
thank you for those words kristin and so
with that to
everybody who has joined us thank you
so much over the course of this week i
hope you've been able to not just get a
sense for who we are
at stanford but i hope you're able to
also get some insights into the process
and hopefully insights into yourself as
you're able to
unpack and untangle all of the different
things that
make you who you are um i really hope
that also
that also provides some of those lenses
for you to
really appreciate and understand those
around you with
empathy thoughtfulness and curiosity
because that's the way that we're really
going to be able to get out there and
solve
the world's problems working together
across difference
celebrating that difference and
realizing the potential that
diverse perspectives have to offer so
with that
this is going to be the last time this
balboa head
will be signing off i want to thank you
again we have
one more event for diversity in
leadership 2020 connect with community
this evening professor huggy rao will be
doing one more case study
and featuring a very special guest so
while i'll be behind the scenes
this is going to be my goodbye to you
hopefully we'll cross
paths again soon and until then take
care
stay safe and keep asking yourself what
matters to you and why